well a couple of years ago producer
colton brought me a video to react to i
was younger
i was more naive the video was
absolutely horrific it was about
something called
pony play apparently there's some sort
of competition where people dress up
like ponies
looking like something out of the
basement in one of those last scenes of
pulp fiction bring out the
it was truly awe-inspiringly
horrendous and i still have nightmares
about this sort of thing so
if you're ready to see me have psychic
pain inflicted
upon myself then um get ready it's about
to happen
again it's just what colton revels in
it's his revenge i gotta tell you
this video is sponsored by ring which i
should have used to protect myself from
what's about to happen here
crossfit has nothing on pet play
my responsibility is similar to the
responsibility
of the regular dog i'm a regular dog i'm
just different
okay i mean maybe she is who are you to
judge
stop that maybe she is a regular dog
just different from all the other dogs
and that she's
a biological human but if she identifies
as a dog she is a dog this is what we've
learned i mean let's be real about this
biology is merely
what your chromosomes say you are but
what you are inside
is what counts i mean not the human
biology that's inside your actual body i
mean what you are in your own head
is what counts these are people who are
dressed up
as dogs in public
for real for real we've been in the la
there's a club six going on seven years
seven years
is to provide a safe space for people
to explode
no and we'll have the best time
there's a there's there's a cl love
don't judge love it love it
i gotta say this is the slogan of the
left is love don't judge so own it guys
this should be like feature this at the
dnc this should be like an actual
constituency
right should be a member of the
intersectional coalition because let's
face it this would be a pretty
victimized sub-group people who believe
that they are dogs and then that is
that is a subgroup i mean people are not
there should be state provided
kibble i mean we absolutely need
some form of leash provided by the state
to make sure that
well spaying and neutering well probably
not that that we like the state's
actually done that before and it's
actually horrific human rights abuse
when you do it on humans but they're
dogs so i mean
i guess we do that to animals right
i don't know it all gets so confusing
i have been informed that this is
actually a series entitled
love don't judge and every week on
snapchat they put up a different bizarre
form of love that you are supposed to
green light because this is our
uh new world it's exciting it's really
exciting
yeah we're going to survive as a
civilization guys it's going to be great
this is tony he fell in love with
andrew wait hold up this is tony he fell
in love with andrew and he was dressed
up as a dog
so that's a weird way to meet that's
that's sort of a meat cute
i guess sort of kind of what now
now i i have to be honest with you the
only person
whose actual gender i think i get here
is andrew
andrew is pretty obviously a biological
male but i have no idea what's going on
in any of the rest of this because
we no longer measure things by objective
criteria it's all about what's inside
your head
so i i i don't follow but okay we'll try
to follow
the first time i met you i was dressed
as a dog for halloween
yeah it didn't seem weird at the time i
just happen to have all the gear
but little did andrew know just how much
significance
that dog costume would have on their
relationship
my name is tony and i'm a human pup
i'm andrew i'm tony's husband and
trainer drop it
drop it drop it
this canine loving couple have one
rather unusual dog living in there oh no
tony regularly spends time oh no living
as a pup
people come to my house and they see my
ribbons and they say oh you've won all
these ribbons at dog shows
but they rarely ask if i'm the dog yeah
yes yes i can understand that honestly
understandable reaction you see a bunch
of dog rubbins like for winning shows
and they rarely ask if i'm the dog
because they're not insane
you're an insane person okay that's like
you walk into somebody's house they have
a bunch of bowling trophies nobody ever
asked if you're the ball
who do you think you are i am because
that would be crazy you're not a bully
what you walk into a house and there's
just a bunch of like
golf trophies on the wall like yeah but
are you a nine iron
that's really the question
i've won quite a few these two are the
best ones i have
because these are my two best in shows i
got these at domicon
who enjoy the practice of pet play
play is anytime that a person takes on
the role
of an animal um and they emulate that
animal
i got into pet play through tony my
responsibility
is similar to the responsibility with a
regular dog
the first dog i'm a regular
dog i'm just different okay so i have a
question if his responsibilities are the
same as they would be with a regular dog
does he clean her poop
or his poop i don't know what what's
going on like it because i
i've seen dog owners and it seems like
this is a regular thing that the dogs
kind of poop on the street and then
like is that a thing that happens or it
only goes so far are there limits to pet
play
if so it doesn't seem like love is
accepted enough here i
don't mean to get graphic but it was
impossible not to go there i can't
believe you've done this
maybe it was possible not to go there
but it's too late we've been there
you've been on this journey with me
let's go the rest of the way on this
horrific journey into the nether regions
of theater webs
i've been involved in pep play for my
entire life my entire life kids like to
play pretend they like to pretend to be
an animal i just never grew out
yeah yeah i hang out and i provide him
with lots of attention and tell him he's
a good boy
that's basically 90 of it i am a good
boy
i think for a lot of pet play couples
that the um
pets get perhaps a little bit more out
of it
[Music]
come on in okay i feel like the person
at the at the horror movie don't go in
that door
don't do it i don't even know what's
behind that door i don't even know
what's coming next
but the minute they went in there
something bad was gonna happen that's my
prediction something bad's gonna happen
inside that house
something that no one likes except the
people involved apparently but you're
not gonna like it and i'm not gonna like
it
but they aren't the only couple who
enjoy spending time
in this pet dynamic we've been in the la
pony and critter club for
six going on seven years
the purpose of the la pony
and critter club is to provide a
safe space for people to explore
no no
and we have just the best time
you're so cute i know
oh my god yeah i don't think that uh our
civilization's gonna be able to fight
off isis
i think we might be toast here this is
pretty
wow wow i do have a question about like
who
provides the you know i don't even wanna
know the answers to who provides the
gear for these sorts of things like it's
like an entire
manufacturing line that does this like
makes
s m horseplay outfits i assume yes
or otherwise they get very creative with
their with their weaving at home
we'll continue with whatever this is in
just one second first it is doorbell
season the busiest time of the year at
your front door
that's definitely true at my house right
now there are a lot of people who are
showing up to deliver holiday
gifts and we want to make sure that we
know who is at the front door plus i
have three kids under the age
of seven i need to keep an eye on all of
them that's why i need ring devices well
if someone stops by something's going on
ring will let you know you can see and
speak to whoever is there from anywhere
this holiday season it's not just the
best time to have ring but the best time
to give it as well
ring makes the perfect holiday gift so
this holiday season gives someone the
gift of peace of mind
ring has security products for every
corner of your home inside now best of
all
you can see it all in the ring app we've
been using ring at our house for
literally years when we moved my wife
said put the ring devices on the house
that was one of the first things we did
she feel safer and more secure and so do
i ring has everything you need
to keep an eye on home this holiday
season and throughout the year you can
see and speak
to whomever is at your door from
anywhere with video doorbells keep an
eye on every corner of your house with
easy to install
indoor and outdoor cams help protect
your whole home with ring alarm a
powerful affordable whole home security
system you can easily install it
yourself for a limited time
head on over to ring.com ben for special
holiday offers again that is ring.com
all right well i guess this this crazy
lady i guess she calls herself a horse
trainer
which is uh weird since there's no horse
involved how long have you been a uh
horseman
oh no oh no before that i was opponent
well okay fine first of all you got to
give credit to people who are really
moving up in the meritocracy like
seriously
that is that is that is really rising in
the world start off as the pony
and then to become the pony trainer that
is something you normally don't see
coming right
it's not like normally you have a dog
and then later your dog becomes
the person who trains your dog where are
my testicles summer
this is a brand new brave world and let
me tell you to be able to move
from being the animal to being the
animal trainer
kudos to that doctor of education from
the university of delaware for everybody
okay i know i know i like the
performance
art for me the quintessential
pet play gear is tail and hood
everything else
okay that's good enough in case you're
just out buying a kit you need like the
essentials but you don't need the
accoutrements
so it's like the tail and the and the
head everything else though you can
leave it home
i mean like you can upgrade always but
this is good this is a practical guide
i have a question yes do you what
sends you into puppy space for me it's
being on all fours
the gear is i don't need the gear the
gear is for
you to see me as a dog while many might
find it hard to comprehend
tony's desire to spend time with the dog
the reason
is not so difficult to understand for me
the reason that i like to be a dog is
dog is man's best friend
hey no don't get me by my tail i'll bite
you dogs experience the world through a
lens of pure joy that i don't think
other animals have
maybe dolphins but i feel like that pet
play would be much harder first of all
i think that that'd be hilarious like
dolphin like that
it would last for like as long as a
human being can hold their breath
essentially
it turns out there are certain
biological hazards who's often pet play
so there's that
also i don't know honestly i feel tony's
being judgmental here tony's being super
judgmental
right because tony's like dogs
experience the world through a lens of
pure joy
in a way other animals don't who is tony
to speak of this is tony a cat
is tony a parakeet is tony a zebra
is tony an armadillo i don't think so
so how the hell would tony know love
don't judge seems pretty judgy to me
tony i don't think pet play is sexual i
do think that to an extent is erotic
because it is intimate yeah i'm feeling
i know my uh husband over there is
independent
sexuality and pep play can be pretty
conscious oh can it
we don't make it sexual but i have
nothing against this
oh my god pet play is first of all great
exercise
it's a lot of fun crossfit has nothing
on pet play
except for you're not insane well maybe
you are if you crossfit too much
tug of war fetch very typical dog
activities
i consider myself out i'm very open that
being said
i do compartmentalize my pet play
because
not everyone wants or needs to see that
well that's because of the
discrimination of our patriarchal
society
frankly i think tony should be able to
walk into his or her job
as a as a teacher at an elementary
public school dress like this
the rest of the world needs to accept
that pet play exists the rest of the
world needs to understand
that there are people who identify as
dogs and they have every right the same
right that you or i have to dress like a
normal human in the workplace
tony has to dress like a dog and run
around barking in the workplace
california anti-discrimination law needs
to be changed today
today to make sure that people like tony
are taken care of i think everyone
should feel comfortable
exploring the limits of their creativity
and imagination i appreciate that i'm
married to someone
who encourages me to explore my
imagination and my interests
wherever they leave and i try to do the
same what is it
my mouth tastes like wood chips yeah i
wonder why
yeah i've been told that love don't
judge is an actual series on snapchat
i just gonna read you the titles of some
of the other episodes
our three-way relationship isn't an
abomination changing gender brought us
closer together
i'm in love with my wife's girlfriend my
husband is an asexual drag queen
we are raising our child as genderfluid
see that one just makes me angry because
now you're a child abuser
we're in a hetero polyquad relationship
that actually just sounds like a sport
nice cat percy
i don't even know what that means what
is a polyquad relationship
it involves four people and they are all
straight but that doesn't work because
if they're all straight just the
mathematic this is like a this is like a
logic problem now
we have four people and they are all
straight how can they be in a
relationship with each other
my husband has a girlfriend and i have a
boyfriend
we opened our marriage after i
transitioned yeah this all sounds like
perfectly normal and healthy behavior
it's a free country you can do what you
want
but i'm also allowed to say this is kind
of crazy yeah love don't judge
how about like love and judge or if
you're letting me just judge
you know alrighty well if you want to
see more of this and why
in the world would you seek help right
now like seriously
go get psychiatric care or go ahead and
click on that subscribe button down
below for the possibility that producer
colton will torture me once again
in the future by the way if you want to
see something else besides this
and honest to god i hope that you want
to see something else besides this
search for
the ben shapiro show on snapchat and
subscribe over there